-Ukrainian president
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
delivered a virtual address
to Congress today
as Vladimir Putin's invasion
of Ukraine continued to sputter,
leaving hope that there can be
a diplomatic solution
to the conflict.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Zelenskyy delivered
a deeply moving
and impassioned address
to Congress today
and received
a bipartisan show of support,
including a standing ovation
the moment he appeared on-screen
before he even said a word.
[ Applause ]
I can say with
absolute certainty
that's the warmest reception
anyone has ever received
on Zoom.
I wish I got a reaction
like that from my staff
when I joined a virtual meeting.
Most of the time
they have me muted,
which becomes clear
when it's their turn to talk.
Okay, Emily,
let's hear what you have.
Emily? Emily?
Emily, can you --
Emily, I see you looking --
Emily.
Emily, did someone just
serve you a hamburger?
Are you --
Emily, are you at a restaurant?
Or even worse, when a member of
my staff Zooms into a meeting --
and again, this is a 100% real
screenshot -- from their bed.
[ Laughter ]
Like our cue card guy Wally did
during a "respect in
the workplace" training.
[ Laughter ]
And just to confirm,
that is Wally and not,
as I originally thought,
Wally's thumb on the lens.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, we drew a face
on a thumb
just to see what
that would look like.
[ Laughter ]
That paid off.
Zelenskyy asked the U.S.
to continue ramping up
the pressure on Russia
to stop its barbaric
and illegal war,
including by imposing
even more punishing sanctions
on Russian oligarchs
and officials.
-New packages of sanctions
are needed constantly every week
until the Russian
military machine stops.
Restrictions are needed
for everyone
on whom this unjust regime
is based.
We propose
that the United States
sanction all politicians
in the Russian Federation
who remain in their offices
and do not cut ties with those
who are responsible
for the aggression
against Ukraine.
-And you can understand
why Zelenskyy
is calling
for additional sanctions,
because the ones
we've already imposed
have squeezed Russia's economy.
They've been cut off from the
international banking system.
Oligarchs are having
their yachts seized.
Even fast-food chains
like Pizza Hut and KFC
are pulling out of the country.
This KFC, by the way.
They still have the other KFC,
Kamchatka Fried Chicken.
Their secret recipe
is one spice, and it's sawdust.
Their slogan is...
And as we mentioned,
Russian oligarchs
are feeling the pain, too.
In fact, today "The New York
Times" reported that...
First of all, I've never heard
of a more perfect description
of a Russian oligarch --
a former KGB agent
who made his money
off nickel mining.
The only way
it could be more perfect
is if he got his start holding
Ivan Drago's spit bucket.
Norway should seize the yacht
and do something fun with it.
Maybe they could add
a buffet and a casino
and make it part
in Norwegian Cruise Lines.
There's no better way
to punish a sleazy rich guy
than turning their yacht into
a cruise ship for the masses.
[ Russian accent ] Vladimir,
you have to stop this war.
American tourists are walking
all over my yacht in flip-flops.
A yacht is no place
for flipping and flopping.
[ Normal voice ]
So the consequences for Russia
have been intense,
and there's likely more coming.
On top of that, it seems
like Putin did not expect
that his barbaric invasion
of Ukraine
would go this badly
or take this long.
As one report put it yesterday,
Putin thought Russia's military
could capture Kyiv in two days,
but it still hasn't in 20,
which explains the new law
he passed
that changes the entire month
of March to one day.
In Russia,
it's always Monday now.
That's why the Russian Garfield
is always so miserable.
Also, they're out of lasagna.
So he was forced to eat
Kamchatka Fried Chicken.
Putin clearly didn't expect such
stiff resistance from Ukraine.
And there are
several reasons for that.
But one may be that...
That doesn't surprise me.
You think anyone around Putin
ever gives him bad news?
[ Russian accent ] Does my butt
look big in these pants?
Remember,
I know where family lives.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
He probably thinks his
childhood dog is still alive.
[ Russian accent ]
My advisers tell me Gorky
went to live at farm upstate.
He is now 57, very successful,
owns nickel mine,
has superyacht.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Just take a look at the faces
on his most senior officials
whenever he has to meet
with them in public.
I mean, that's not the vibe
of a group of people
who've just been told, "There
are no wrong answers here."
Last time I looked around a room
and saw facial expressions
like that,
I was at my
gastroenterologist's office.
And, by the way,
I can make colonoscopy jokes now
because I'm 48,
which used to surprise people,
you know, before COVID.
I mean, look at me
from back then.
I looked like
the kid from "Belfast," and...
[ Laughter ]
...now I look like the grandpa
from "Belfast."
I never got to meet
Jamie Dornan in Belfast.
I said to my wife, "Do
you think I look a little
bit like Jamie Dornan?"
And she said,
"After what happened to him?"
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Putin obviously
does not tolerate dissent.
And now he's overseeing
a vicious crackdown
on free speech in Russia,
which is why it was so shocking
and courageous
when an employee
of Russian state TV
interrupted a broadcast
this week
to protest the war live on air.
-The Russian journalist
who held up a sign
in the middle of a show that
read, in part, "Stop the war.
Do not believe propaganda.
They tell you lies here."
And, "Russians against war."
-The program appeared
to quickly cut away to video.
-Yeah, I bet they cut away.
They cut away faster
than "SNL" did
when Ashlee Simpson
was busted lip-synching.
Lorne Michaels still
doesn't know that happened.
And if you're thinking,
"Well, now he does,
because you just said it,"
I'm sorry to tell you,
Lorne doesn't even know
this show exists.
He still thinks Colin Jost
is subbing for me
while I'm on my honeymoon.
But, I mean, look at that.
That is an incredibly
brave protest,
knowing the likely consequences.
In fact, it's hard to fully
grasp just how brave that is
because we take free speech
for granted here.
Usually the only interruptions
from someone holding a sign
on this show are from Wally.
-Did I hear my name?
-What?
What in the world does
"Use promo code 'Wally'" mean?
-Seth, I have a new sponsorship
with a mattress company,
thanks to that Zoom photo
of me in bed blowing up.
-What mattress company?
-I'm glad you asked.
It's called MyMattress Guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, good. Yeah.
Encourage him.
That'll be helpful.
Do, by all means, encourage him.
The point is, unlike Wally,
that was an incredibly
courageous act of protest.
In fact, to give you an idea
of how bad it's gotten,
a Russian newspaper tweeted
a photo of the protest.
But thanks to Russia's
extreme new censorship laws,
this is what it looked like.
I mean, look at that.
Putin wants you to think someone
interrupted a state TV broadcast
to hold up a giant
blank piece of paper.
The only time I've ever seen
an actual blank piece of paper
on national TV like that
was when Trump pretended
he was signing a bill
or writing one of his speeches.
Remember that, when he posed --
posed for a photo
and pretended he was writing
his own inaugural address
with a Sharpie?
A Sharpie.
Are you writing a speech
or labeling your lunch
for the office fridge?
Looks like an author photo
on a dust cover
for a book called
"Business Acting 101."
[ Laughter ]
Putin clearly miscalculated,
in part because he's so isolated
from reality.
Now the blowback
has been so intense,
Russia has been cut off from
the global financial system,
and even fast-food chains
are pulling out.
So if you go to a KFC in Moscow
and they tell you
it's definitely chicken,
just remember their new slogan.
-"They tell you lies here."
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.